let's bring you some other news from
around the world now at least 128 people
have been killed after a shallow 5.6
magnitude earthquake struck Nepal's
mountainous Northwestern districts of
jarot and rum Rescue helicopters have
flown into the region to help and
security forces are digging out the
injured and the dead from the rubble
officials say they expect the death toll
to rise let back to Ramat limbo she's in
the nepales capital kandu just bring us
up to date with uh the situation at the
moment in terms of the rescues and
what's been
happening uh yes uh Saturday morning uh
nepales uh across the country woke up to
the news uh of an earthquake around
midnight on uh Friday uh Tremors who
felt in Katmandu and as far west as
Delhi and India but the most severely
struck areas are the mountain areas of
Jer courot uh and Western rukum
currently the hospitals are overwhelmed
um because of uh lack of Manpower and um
uh uh provinces across and around the
area are sending in reinforcements
medical reinforcements uh doctors um the
Army and security forces are conducting
a search and rescue uh operation because
the first 24 hours after the earthquake
is a crucial period after which uh
recovery and Rehabilitation work will
start of course it's been challenging
because uh judger Court and Western
rukum in the remote carali Province um
are among the most uh poorest and
underdeveloped areas Road there are very
few roads or even if there are roads
there are still many areas that you can
only reach by foot and The Villages are
widespread and Scattered so apparently
the uh security forces are finding that
quite challenging in reaching out uh to
these areas uh the central government
and other provisional governments have
rallied to support uh the region by
providing uh financial aid and other
humanitarian resources and the Nepal
government has also uh called out to
International organizations to support
um humanitarian and Recovery um
Rehabilitation efforts uh ramata is this
an area that normally uh or shall we say
fairly often gets situations like this
is there any sort of prevention that
people there have been able to put in
place before something like this
happened or are they relying entirely on
help from
outside well um as you know in 2015
Nepal did suffer from a a very big
earthquake in which 9,000 people uh more
than 9,000 people died and since then
there have been efforts uh policies to
try to bring a disaster preparedness um
policies into place and they are being
um implemented across R the country but
again uh Western uh Nepal the
mountainous region of Western Nepal is
very remote uh villages are scattered uh
communication is not the best um so and
then medical supplies hospitals um are
uh very um there limited uh Human
Resources uh there um but there have
been efforts definitely to improve the
disaster preparedness uh risk of Earth
wakes floods landslides in recent years
but there can be uh so much more done
ramata thank you very much indeed we're
going to be coming back to you of course
as those rescue operations continue but
for now rat Limu thank you very much